our gracious heavenly father father we
are so grateful to be here and have the
opportunity to open your word to study
together
and yet father we know that as we open
the word as we
seek to understand
more of this wonderful gift of Prophecy
father the the spirit that inspired
the prophet must also Inspire us as we
seek to understand your will and your
ways and your teachings in this in
regard to this gift and I pray Lord for
a special blessing of your Holy Spirit
upon this class today
the father blessed me as the speaker
bless the class as hearers that
we won't be receiving my words but
father we will understand your words
today
and father I'm asking this in the name
of Jesus and for his sake amen
okay one of the first things that I want
to touch on
as I said this class I'm looking for
markers here
I started out
in fact a lot of the things that we're
looking at today I started I did a
sermon series
and I entitled that series by a prophet
because
I was alarmed at the
fact that many
even of my own Seventh-day Adventist
Church members even of people who've
been in the church their whole lives
could not give a good reason from the
Bible why they believed in the spirit of
Prophecy okay there's a there's a thing
that you'll hear spoken sometimes
people will say a Seventh-Day Adventist
we believe in
the Bible
and
the spirit of Prophecy have you heard
that before
now I'm going to challenge that
okay
but before I do that
I'm going to say that's a lot like
saying we believe that we're saved
by faith
and
Works have you ever heard anybody say
that
you will
you will and uh not all not everybody
necessarily knows what they mean or
means what that may sound like when they
say it but I've had people say this in
fact this was one of the things that uh
when I became a minister in in the Ohio
conference one of the things that they
asked they asked a question one of the
questions they asked me coming in are We
safe bye
faith alone
are we saved by works or are we saved by
faith and works
I was the answer
thank you
faith that works brother and and it was
amen
and the reason that they worded that way
and I saw and I understand some people
hear that and they don't want to answer
faith alone because they hear that you
know sometimes when people say faith
alone they're not necessarily talking
about Bible faith
Ellen White talked about people who said
we're saved by faith alone and they
emphasize this
and she says that's true in the fullest
sense
but she says a lot of people don't take
it in the fullest sense their faith
alone means a faith that doesn't obey
Christ a faith that doesn't yield their
will to God's Supreme will okay
but the truth that the fact remains that
we're not saved by faith and works
we're saved by faith
of faith that works a true Living Faith
do you follow me and we don't believe in
the Bible and the spirit of Prophecy we
believe in a Bible that teaches the
spirit of Prophecy we believe in the
Bible
we believe in Sola scriptura and listen
to me my young brothers and sisters
it's because of our belief in the Bible
and that alone
that we believe in the gift of Prophecy
is manifested through Illinois
we can't not believe in the gift of
Prophecy and I'm hoping that if nothing
else at the end of this class what will
be clear in your mind is as a
bible-believing Christian I can't not
believe that Ellen White was a prophet
sent by God
okay
the Bible is plain on this
and so that's going to be our goal in
this class
so that you can have a confidence
not so I can have a confidence you know
it's so important and I know
that any teacher Pastor Wallace I'm sure
has been trying to you know the burden
of the teacher is that not that I have
the confidence I know what I believe
and I don't want you to know what I
believe
I want you to know what you believe
I want you to leave the class with a
clear confidence
that this is what I believe
because you're never going to be able to
stand in life for something that I
believe
amen
okay
the first text I want you to go with
kind of an overarching text and what
we're looking at is in Hosea chapter 12.
it's right after the Book of Daniel
Hosea chapter 12 is really a fascinating
text here
Hosea chapter 12 and verse 13.
okay
and as I'm looking over the class you
all seem to be doing fairly well you
know the worst class to teach Pastor
Wallace is the one after lunch
you know and and the room is even a
little bit it's a little on the warm
side here
you know and what happens after lunch
when you get that full stomach get a
little bit of a warm room you know
as you start to doze off so I will make
an example out of you if you start to
sleep in my class
Jose
let's hit 12. no seriously I was telling
somebody at lunch I don't know you had
Pastor Richard o'fill this year well he
just spoke at our church in Grand Rapids
this last weekend and uh he said that
right up front he said you know he says
if you're gonna fall asleep in my class
he says you better have eyes painted on
your eyelids so it looks like you're
awake when you're sleeping because he
says if I catch you sleeping I'm going
to make an example out of you and he did
we had a fella who was dozing off in the
class and I thought yeah that's a good
idea that'll keep them on their toes all
right Hosea 12 13.
Hosea 12 13
the Bible says now I'm using the new
King James version here by a prophet the
Lord brought Israel out of Egypt
and by a prophet he was what
preserved by a prophet God brought
Israel out of Egypt and by a prophet
Israel was preserved now
I want you to keep that in mind as we
look at our next text and that's in
First Corinthians chapter 10.
and this is all just by way of
introduction here first Corinthians
First Corinthians chapter 10 and this is
probably review for a lot of you
but there's nothing wrong with review is
there repetition deepens what
that's right
First Corinthians chapter 10
First Corinthians chapter 10. now I want
you to start in verse one with me
First Corinthians 10 in fact let's flesh
this out quite a bit because I think
this goes very much with what we're
talking about First Corinthians 10 1 the
Apostle says here moreover Brethren I do
not want you to be unaware that what
that what what's that word there all our
fathers all our fathers were under the
cloud and what
how many pass through the sea all pass
through the sea how many were baptized
all were baptized into Moses in the
cloud and in the sea verse 3 starts with
what word all ate the same spiritual
food and what
all drank the same spiritual drink you
see a pattern there don't you
Paul says all of our fathers you know
here we are the children of Israel all
of our fathers came out of Egypt they
all went through the Wilderness they'll
pass through they passed through the Red
Sea together they were under that cloud
they witnessed the mighty miracles of
god in Deliverance
all of them did
but something changes
he says all drank the Same Spirit to
drink for they drank of that spiritual
rock that followed them and that rock
was who
was Christ but verse 5 says but with
what
but with who
most of them
what happened
God was not pleased
with most of them God was not pleased
for their bodies were scattered in the
wilderness in essence he's saying they
all went to the same church they all
went to the same church school they'll
put money in the same offering plate
they went to the same Sabbath School
class they went to the same church
socials
but with all that most of them died in
the wilderness
we're not saved by association you know
that
we're not saved because we hang out in
Christian groups
Ellen White commenting on The Virgins
the ten virgins the parable of the ten
virgins
she says those five foolish virgins that
had no oil in their lamps she says these
were not Hypocrites the Bible says
they're virgins they had a pure faith
she said they loved the truth they loved
the people of the truth they like to be
around the people who believe the truth
but they didn't fall in the Rock Christ
Jesus and let their heart be broken up
you see they didn't have an experience
in the things of God
now the setting of this is very
interesting Paul gives us this this uh
introduction he says I don't want you to
be ignorant I don't want you to be aware
that even though all our fathers came
through that wonderful Mighty experience
and saw the miracles of god most of them
didn't make it
what is it what do you think that tells
the people that Paul's talking to
what what is that conveying to them
we better be more alert huh boy if if
they could all go through that
experience and most of them
be lost
then we need to be on our toes don't we
okay and this is what he's saying now he
says these things happen verse six these
things became our what
examples to the intent that we should
what
not less after evil things as they
lusted and he begins to list several
experiences of the children of Israel in
verse 11 he Recaps again and he says now
all these things happen to them as what
examples and they were written for who
sort of
they're written for R my Bible says
admonition anybody have a different word
what's an admonition
instruction
warning
these things happened in and God wrote
these things down you ever read those
Old Testament stories and say that's
interesting but man what's that have to
do with me
the Apostle Paul says it has everything
to do with you and me isn't that right
these things were written for our
example
they were rather they happened to them
as examples they were written for our
admonition upon whom the what
the ends of the ages the ends of the
world have come those of us living at
the very last moments of Earth history
that's what this was written for okay
now Hosea chapter 12 13 as we just read
it buy a prophet
God brought Israel out of Egypt and by a
prophet God preserved his people
they would have all been lost in the
wilderness if it hadn't been for the
faithfulness of the prophet
and today
I
I would imagine that not one of us would
make it if God hadn't in his Mercy sent
a prophet to guide his people just like
he did then
these things happened to them as
examples for us and when we read that
text in Hosea we said oh that's
interesting it's a nice little text that
talks about what happened way back when
no
they're written for those of us upon
whom the ends of the world have come
God brought his people out under the
guidance of a prophet
and God preserved them
by the guidance of a prophet that's the
role and we're going to look at that
today at this in the time that we have
today we're going to take a look at the
gift of Prophecy and the purpose of the
gift of Prophecy
the first thing I want to do is go to
the Bible and just get a very simple
Bible definition of what a prophet is
okay
what is a prophet let's go to the Book
of Exodus
let's go to the Book of Exodus chapter
4.
Exodus chapter 4
interesting little passage of scripture
here
Exodus chapter 4 we're going to pick up
in verse 10.
this is when the Lord had come to Moses
and told Moses he wanted him to lead
Israel this is the prophet that God
raised up
that we were just reading about
God comes to Moses in
I love the story of Moses
Moses was we know the battle the story
of the little basketball he was raised
up in the king in the pharaoh's Palace
and he was trained as a military genius
in Egypt
and when the time and and uh from the
time he was young
he understood that God was going to
raise up he understood the miraculous
preservation when he was young and he
knew God had promised a deliverer and he
realized that that was his purpose
sister white tells us that specifically
the Bible will allude to that
but as Moses got older and that day came
where he was seeing the one of his
Hebrew one of the Hebrew people
oppressed by an Egyptian
you remember what happened
he went and he killed the Egyptian task
master
figured it's time now is now it's time
I'm going to come in here and I'm going
to take care of this guy and I'm going
to lead my people out
only it didn't quite go as he planned
right
his own people turned on him didn't
trust him and Moses fled
for his life and spent 40 years in the
wilderness of Midian
now remember he was a trained gen
General in Egypt he knew all the
military strategies
he was as far as human appearances go
probably in the best shape to lead any
army
but after 40 years in the wilderness of
Midian as a shepherd
you ever forget things you learned
huh
well I better not say that you know are
you going to quiz these guys
you might forget some of the things you
learned last week um
I asked my church I'll preach up and say
what you remember what we talked about
last week we commit a sermon series
40 years later Moses has forgotten
everything and the Lord says okay Moses
now it's time and look at Moses response
verse 10. then Moses said to the Lord oh
my Lord I'm not eloquent
neither before nor sins have you spoken
to your servants no sorry neither before
nor sins you have spoken to your servant
but I'm slow of speech and slow of
tongue I've been out of Egypt so long I
forget the language I don't know how how
am I going to go in there now Lord I'm
able to quit I I I'm not able I'm not
capable I don't have the skill to go in
and do what you're asking me to do
hmm you guys ever say something like
that
let's go out and knock on those doors I
don't know how to do it let's give a
Bible so I've never given a bible study
on that before
I'm slow of speech and slow of tongue
verse 11 so the Lord said to him oh take
note of this
so the Lord said to him who's made man's
mouth
who makes the mute the deaf the seeing
the blind have I have not I the Lord now
therefore go
incidentally somebody's probably brought
this up the word therefore when you read
we're there for what do you do
ask what it's there for therefore means
what
what does the word therefore mean
for this reason notice what he says
Moses who made man's mouth now for this
reason Moses go
I made your mouth now for this reason go
he says and I will be with your mouth
and teach you what you shall say and
Moses did just like you and I do so
often but he said oh my Lord please send
by the hand of whoever else you'll send
anybody but me
and so it says in verse 14 so the anger
of the Lord was kindled against Moses
and he said is not Aaron the Levites
your brother I know that he can speak
well and look he's also coming out to
meet you when he sees you you will be
glad he will be glad in his heart
now you shall speak to him and put the
words in his what
mouth mouth and I will be with your
mouth and with with his mouth and I will
teach you what you should do
so he shall be your what
he shall be your what
some of you got it he should be your
what this is important
he shall be your spokesman to the people
and he himself shall be as a mouth for
you and you shall be to him as who
as God now go from there with that fresh
in your mind to chapter 7 and verse 1.
Exodus chapter 7 and verse 1.
Exodus chapter 7 and verse 1. notice
what it says so the Lord said to Moses
see I have made you as God to pharaoh
and Aaron your brother shall be your
what
your what
a prophet is a what
a spokesman
very simply put Bible definition a
prophet is a spokesman a prophet is not
necessarily a fortune teller
a lot of people think oh Prophet Prophet
tells the future a prophet simply speaks
for God
a prophet is a special spokesman for God
did you follow that
yeah okay
let's look at that one other place
Jeremiah chapter one
Jeremiah chapter 1 notice we'll start in
verse 5
Jeremiah 1 and verse 5.
the Bible says here before I formed you
in the womb I knew you before you were
born I Sanctified you I ordained you a
what a prophet to the Nations now look
at what Jeremiah says look at this we're
following we're running over the same
ground again
then said I Jeremiah says Ah Lord God
behold I I can't speak for I'm a youth
but the Lord said to me do not say I am
a youth for I shall go I'm sorry for you
shall go to all whom I shall send you
and whatever I command you you shall
speak don't be afraid of their faces for
I am with you to deliver you says the
Lord then the Lord put forth his hand
and touched my mouth and the Lord said
to me behold I have put what word my
words in your mouth what was Jeremiah
a prophet a spokesman
you follow that that's what a prophet is
uh in the Hebrew
and we'll look at this a little bit more
later but in the Hebrew the word
uh for Prophet Nabi
means
spokesman or spokesperson that's what
the Hebrew word means throughout the Old
Testament you read the word Prophet the
Hebrew word is Nami it means
spokesperson
in the New Testament the word for
Prophet is the Greek word prophetes
which means
one who speaks forth
a spokesperson
okay
so you've got a little Greek and Hebrew
definition you've got the Bible
definition a spokesperson for the Lord
that's what a prophet is interestingly
enough the difference between a prophet
and a priest is that a priest
is in a position of one who speaks to
God in behalf of man
and the prophet is one who speaks to man
in behalf of God
okay
so let's go from here
to the next point that I would like to
make
Prophet is a spokesperson for the Lord
now did God ever speak to his people
through means other than Prophets
okay what are some of the ways can
somebody tell me
a donkey
I wonder if that would make the donkey a
prophet
he did speak through a donkey what else
Angels okay what else
what's that
nature
the heavens declare the glory of God
what are some other ways God
communicated to ancient Israel
okay dreams
okay
look with me to First Samuel chapter 28.
first Samuel
chapter 28. now you may remember the
story of King Saul
King Saul had rejected the Lord's
counsel King Saul had rebelled against
the Lord and had hardened his heart
against the Lord he refused to submit to
the Lord and though outwardly he may
like he really wanted to know the Lord's
will yet in his heart he didn't want to
know the Lord's will so the Lord wasn't
answering
Saul and in the book of Samuel first
Samuel chapter 28
verse 6
. I want you to notice what it says here
Saul had been inquiring now Samuel the
prophet had died Saul had always gone to
Samuel the prophet well Samuel had
passed on okay
so in verse 6 it says here and when Saul
inquired of the Lord
the Lord did not answer him either by
what
dreams or by what urim or by thee
prophets what was Europe does anybody
know
okay the stones on the breastplate
that was another way that God
communicated right the urum and the
thumb and when the breastplate of the
high priest's garment God would speak
through that emitting light on the want
through the one or a shadow or Cloud
over the other okay so there were
different ways God communicated with his
people and I just wanted to make that
point and we know that we see that in
different places however
God's modus operandi God's mode of
operation God's favorite and and primary
means of communicating his truth to his
people was via the prophet okay
one of the texts that you know on that
one is Amos 3 7 probably one of the
plainest texts
Daniel Hosea Joel Amos chapter 3 and
verse 7.
you can probably say it with me surely
the Lord God does nothing
unless he Reveals His what
his secrets to the what
to his servants the prophets
God revealed his secrets and it says
there Amos says surely the Lord God will
do how much nothing unless he Reveals
His Secrets he's going to reveal his
secrets to the people God wants us to
know what's going on doesn't he
okay when it's for our good to know God
reveals it surely he'll do nothing and I
would say nothing that he knows pertains
to our Eternal salvation unless he
reveals to us that secret through
the prophets
okay
God's mode of communication
is through the prophet God had spoken
audibly in times he's spoken face to
face at times he's spoken through
different means
but God's primary mode of communication
has been through the prophets
okay prophets aren't new we talk about
it well the Ellen White Brothers and
Sisters the Bible is full of prophets
Ellen White's not the only Prophet that
ever was and a person said I don't know
if I believe in prophets get rid of your
Bible
it was written by Prophets
so we've got to understand this this is
how God has chosen to communicate his
truth to his people
now briefly I want to touch on the three
modes of inspiration that God uses when
God communicates a message there's three
modes
that we're going to discuss the mode of
Revelation and this will be brief the
mode of Revelation
the mode of inspiration and the mode of
Illumination
okay
revelation
Revelation is simply the act of
disclosing the information in other
words God gives the information to the
Prophet by what we call Revelation he
reveals it to them
Revelation is the act of disclosing the
information
the informational content of the message
is communicated
that's communicated to us through the
prophet is given to the Prophet by
revelation
inspiration is the process by which God
enables the prophet both to receive and
to communicate the information that was
revealed to him
so first there's Revelation to the
prophet then through inspiration the
prophet receives the message and
communicates the message
and illumination
is the work of the holy spirit in
enabling you and I to receive the
message of the prophet
question
if God has revealed a message to the
prophet
and the prophet through inspiration has
communicated the message to you and I
does that mean you and I are going to
get it
why not
what's that
we need illumination
illumination is the means by which the
Holy Spirit enables us to receive the
message
this is why Pastor Moore was talking
last night in the meeting about the
young man who had the whole Bible
memorized in Hebrew
but yet was not a Christian
I've encountered number numerous people
and you will too when you get Bible
studies they've read all kinds they know
all kinds of stuff about the Bible and
all these other religions but they've
never I had an Evangelistic meeting just
this last summer and had a guy coming
out to that meeting he studied with the
Jehovah's Witnesses he studied with the
Mormons he studied with the Baptist he
studied with everybody he's got a little
piece of all kinds of information
and unless that man yields to Jesus
Christ he's a lost man no matter how
much information he has in his head
illumination is the work of the Holy
Spirit and I want to tell you something
illumination comes when you and I humble
ourselves before the Lord and we allow
the Lord to teach us and we admit that
we need taught
we that's that's the biggest hurdle to
Salvation it's not that salvation is not
free it's that too many of us are are so
naturally proud and we just I don't need
it God I figured out on my own
illumination without illumination
you and I can't grasp the message that
God is communicating through the prophet
listen to the statement here I'm going
to share with you
from the book reflecting Christ
uh originally from the review and Herald
of October 1 1901. Ellen White says the
following she says the holy spirit is
present with the earnest searcher
this is talking about illumination here
it's illumination the Holy Spirit shines
upon the word stamping the truth upon
the mind with a new Fresh importance
the Searcher is filled with a sense of
peace and joy never before felt the
preciousness of Truth is revealed as
never before a new Heavenly light shines
upon the word Illuminating it as though
every letter were tinged with gold
have you ever studied your Bible like
that
there's something about it when the Holy
Spirit touches upon the word and it just
you see something that you've never seen
and you know what you and I can have
that experience every day
because the truth is eternal you know
the danger is when you think you've got
the Bible figured out
I talked to somebody he's not in here so
I can talk about him I talked to
somebody at the meeting last night
afterwards and he said I said did you
learn anything new tonight he said nope
he said have mercy
you come to me I know this stuff I heard
all this stuff before you're not
listening
this is kind of a little sidetracked
when I want you to look in your Bibles I
should have started out with this I
usually start out any class I do with
this text First Corinthians 8 2.
First Corinthians 8 2. make it your
motto
First Corinthians
chapter 8
and verse 2 who wants to read that for
me
we'll we'll go one and two that's kind
of right no no two will work
eight two who wants to read that for me
yes sir
If any man and that goes for you ladies
too
If any man think he knows what
anything he knows how much nothing as he
ought to know it don't ever get in the
mode of thinking you got it figured out
if you do you've just shut yourself off
from the light God wants to reveal to
you
because every time we get every time we
come to the word God wants to reveal
something new but sometimes we come with
that attitude can you imagine going to
somebody's house for dinner taking lunch
today how many of you want to eat today
anybody hungry today what are we having
chili no sorry I had that six years ago
I know what that tastes like
you wouldn't do it would you
there's no sense to do that with the
word of God the Bread of Heaven now I've
tasted that bread before it's always new
it's always new
and the Lord so she says here a new
Heavenly light shines upon the word when
the Holy Spirit illumines illuminates
our mind Illuminating it as though every
letter were tinged with gold God himself
has spoken to the mind and the Heart
God himself has communicated
you know I think about it even I see it
I see it even in our church with pastors
sometimes you know big speakers I
remember when I was in the world as that
when I before I gave my heart to Christ
and you could be to the concerts and
stuff and oh if I could meet so and so
and get their autograph you see people
lining up to talk to some man some woman
we have an audience with God God himself
has spoken in the mind and heart and
where are we you know
making the word spirit and life
eternal life is the receiving of the
living elements in the scriptures the
doing of the will of God the Holy Spirit
illuminates us
and without that illumination the
Revelation and inspiration helps the
prophet but doesn't help you and I so we
have to be willing and open to the Lord
Illuminating us
with the words of the prophet I want you
to turn with me to Revelation chapter
one and we're going to see a little
channel of communication here
surely the Lord God does nothing unless
he Reveals His secret to his servant the
prophet let's go to Revelation chapter
one we'll see kind of a chain of
a hierarchy if you want to call it a
prophetic communication Revelation 1
starting in verse 1
Revelation 1 and verse 1
it says here the revelation of Jesus
Christ
which who
God gave who him him who Jesus so say
God gave Jesus to show his what
servants things which he must things
which must shortly take place and he
send and signified it by his what
angel
to his servant John so you have God
has a message and he sends it to
and our hierarchy there Jesus Christ in
this little
chain of command and then Jesus gives it
to
his servants through
an angel
so Jesus sends the angel to his prop no
no wait to his servants
let's read that because he you know John
kind of expounds on verse 1 and verse
two
the revelation of Jesus Christ which God
gave him to show his servants so in
verse 1 you have God to Jesus to the
servants
but then he kind of expands this a
little bit
and he sent it
and signified it by his Angel to his
servant John Who Bore witness to the
what to the word of God so he sends it
by the angel to the
prophet
to his
servants
okay
do you get that
so God communicated a message to his
servants but how did God do it he sent
it through the angel who gave it to the
prophet
God gave it to his son Jesus who gave to
the angel who gave to the prophet who
gives to the servants
now you and I would really like if God
could just give it right to me
a lot of people today would like it just
write to me I don't like to have to
depend on the prophets people today so I
don't think we need the Bible
God talks right to me
well
this is the chain of command the
scripture shows us God speaks to the
prophet you and I don't have to like it
but that's the way God did it God spoke
to the prophet and then the prophet
communicated it to you and I and if it
hadn't been the for the prophets
communicating this to you and I you and
I didn't have the Visions the scripture
was based on
you and I I did not have the Divine
Revelations that the scripture was based
on
if it weren't for the prophets we
wouldn't have this
we have nothing
so we can boast how much we don't need
Prophets
that's just foolishness
that's how God has chosen to communicate
his message you follow that
okay
now what I want to do
one more thing I'm going to look at
before I break
is who specifically the now the Bible
will point out besides this little
hierarchy we see here the Bible points
out to us specifically who speaks
through the prophet
does anybody have an ESV here
I read this earlier now I'm trying to
think of the text I was reading First
Corinthians
First Corinthians chapter
I'm not knocking the SV by the way but I
just want to point out to you something
that this this thought that's come into
um this understanding of what we believe
the testimony of Jesus is
let's hold off on that for a minute let
me let me get to these other texts first
I want you to go with me
to Revelation chapter
12.
and verse 17.
now we're going to spend more time than
this this is we're just brushing past
this Revelation 12 17 right now
we're going to spend a quite a bit of of
time going through the scripture and
really anchoring ourselves on this
understanding that God has clearly
pointed out in the scripture that his
last day church will have the gift of
Prophecy but we're just going to look at
Revelation 12 17.
and some corresponding texts Revelation
12 17 notice what it says here the
dragon was what
enraged with a woman and he went to make
war with the rest of her Offspring or
the remnant of her seed who keep the
Commandments of God and have the what
okay they have the testimony
what
of
Jesus Christ
does anybody have of something that
reads differently than this
any of your Bibles read differently
that's what I'm looking for
no
okay
now we typically a Seventh-Day Adventist
when we're trying to figure out this
testimony of Jesus Christ we go to the
Book of Revelation chapter 19 and we let
scripture interpret itself amen
Revelation 19 and verse 10.
now John is standing here with the angel
who is communicating to him this message
and it says in verse 10 and I fell at
his feet to what
to worship him but he said to me see
that you do not do that
I am your what
fellow servant and of your what Brethren
who have the testimony what of Jesus
okay there it is Testament of Jesus
worship God
for the testimony of Jesus what
is
the what
Spirit of Prophecy does anybody's Bible
say anything different there
what's the testimony of Jesus
the spirit of Prophecy now I want you to
uh
we're going to come back to that I want
you to look at First Corinthians with me
chapter 5.
I'm sorry for chapter one First
Corinthians chapter 1 verse 5.
First Corinthians chapter 1
verse 5.
let me get it in here
some of you have the ESV I'll ask you
what it says
when we read it
First Corinthians chapter 1 now I'm
reading in the new King James version
listen to what it says
I'm going to start in verse 4. Paul says
here I thank my God always concerning
you for the grace of God which was given
you by Jesus Christ
that you were enriched in everything by
him
in all utterance in all knowledge even
as the testimony of Christ was confirmed
in you
there it is the testimony of Jesus the
spirit of Prophecy does somebody have
something that reads different
huh
the testimony about Christ
there are a lot of people today
that are starting to get this idea and
they're saying that when we read in
Revelation 19 10
that the spirit of Prophecy is the
testimony the testimony of Jesus is the
spirit of Prophecy
rather than being the testimony of Jesus
Christ they say no the testimony about
Jesus Christ that's not talking about
prophets that's just talking about
ordinary people who are telling others
about Jesus
okay
and so they say when we're here we're
building up this whole Doctrine saying
the last day church is going to have a
prophet and they said you guys are crazy
all it's saying is that the last day of
church is going to be telling people the
gospel
has anybody heard that before
you will
you will you hear more and more of this
and I'll tell you what here's the sad
part
most of it is coming from inside
or people who have been inside
okay
so I want you to look again at
Revelation as we were there in
Revelation 19 10. now this is just the
Bible makes this very plain for us we're
going to look at
uh 1910 again we're going to look at
another text another two texts and then
we're going to take a break
Revelation 19 10. I want you to notice
the language I want you to get the
setting of what we're looking at because
we're going to see the same thing again
just a little bit later in Revelation
Revelation 19 10.
says John fell at this Angel seat to
worship him and he said see that you
don't do it
I am your fellow servant and of your
brethren who have the testimony of Jesus
worship God for the testimony of Jesus
is the what
Spirit of Prophecy and they say you're
not John they're not talking he's not
talking about prophets here he's talking
about just people who prophesy about
Jesus they talk about the Gospel of
Jesus well hold your finger there and go
to revelation 22 with me
and look at verse 8 and see the exact
same thing but praise the Lord he just
worded it just a little bit different so
that these people would bring in these
crazy ideas are silenced
revelation 22 verse 8. thank you
revelation 22 verse 8.
the Bible says here now I John saw and
heard these things and when I heard and
saw I fell down to worship before the
feet of the Angel oh look at that we
just saw that didn't we and what does
the angel do in verse 9 then he said to
me see that you what
don't do it and then he says I'm your
fellow what hey we heard that before too
didn't we I'm your fellow servant and of
your brethren the what the prophets
is he just talking about people who tell
people about Jesus no he's talking about
the prophet
the spirit of Prophecy is not some means
of being a spokesperson about the gospel
the spirit of Prophecy is the gift the
prophetic gift that God gave
specifically to the prophets see that
you don't do what he says I am of your
brethren the prophets and of those who
keep the words of this book worship God
and notice the setting of it
notice the setting what is the Angel
saying here's John the Angels telling
him a message and John is so overwhelmed
at the message it's such a powerful
message he's just like oh and the angel
says no ah don't do that don't do that
why because the testimony that I'm
giving you isn't mine
it's coming from Jesus Christ therefore
worship God don't worship me that's the
essence of what he's saying that's why
he says don't do that worship God why
for or because
the testimony of Jesus is the spirit of
Prophecy
I'm just giving you a message that came
from Jesus I'm not do any credit that's
what the Angel's telling John
so the prophetic gift the prophet is a
spokesperson for God and who is it that
the Bible tells us is speaking through
the prophet
who's the testimony coming from
who's the one that gives this testimony
it's Jesus the testimony of Jesus is the
spirit of Prophecy
you've got people today who say to us oh
you Seventh-day Adventist we we believe
in Jesus you guys believe in this
Prophet you don't believe in Jesus oh
wait a minute
the Bible says it's Jesus who chose to
speak to the prophets
now as a believer in Jesus I choose to
believe whatever Jesus tells me through
whatever means he decides to use amen
amen amen
amen and the Bible says I didn't say it
and you didn't say it and the general
conference didn't come up with this
the Bible says that Jesus has chosen to
use the gift of Prophecy amen
one other text just to flesh it out a
little bit more and we'll take our break
it's in First Peter
I'm sorry I'm going to Second Peter
chapter one
no I was right I was first Peter
please forgive the pastor
First Peter chapter 1 verse 10.
now Peter is is telling about the
wonderful uh news the message of the
beautiful message of the Gospel the
message of Salvation through Christ the
message of Salvation incidentally that
had been prophesied throughout the
scripture
and he says this in verse 10 First Peter
chapter 1 and verse 10 of this salvation
that I'm telling you about in essence of
this salvation the prophets have
inquired and searched carefully
who prophesied of the grace that would
come to you what does it mean to inquire
to ask the prophets of this salvation
the prophets have asked and searched
carefully who prophesied get the message
the prophet who gave the message was
asking
what
what were they asking
of this salvation the prophets have
inquired and searched carefully who
prophesied of the grace that would come
to you let's keep on reading and I'll
ask it again searching what or what
manner of time the spirit of Christ who
was in them was indicating when he
testified beforehand the sufferings of
Christ and the glories that would follow
what was he asking what was the prophet
asking what were these prophets asking
yeah in essence follow me they were
asking what does it all mean
do you follow that
do you ask questions that you know the
answers to
not generally
they were inquiring now this is going to
be important later on that the prophets
did not understand everything that God
told them
I may give you a message to take to
somebody
I've done it before I've called you Ben
and I've said hey Ben go tell pastor
ashrick this he'll know what I mean
so Ben goes all right I'm going to go
over and he tells him and he has no clue
what he's telling him he's just
repeating what I told him to say the
pastor astric knows what I was saying
because it's you follow me the prophets
carry the message but that didn't mean
they understood every piece of the
message now who are they speaking to
especially
look at what it says in the next verse
to them to the prophets verse 12 it was
revealed that not to themselves but to
who
but to us they were ministering the
things which now have been reported to
you through those who have preached the
gospel to you by the Holy Spirit Sent
From Heaven things which Angels desire
to look into
the prophet's bore a message that they
themselves didn't fully understand why
because it wasn't for them it was for us
right
isn't that what happened to Daniel go
that way Daniel
you'll stand in your lot at the end of
the days but the message isn't for you
it's for the End of Time
right
and Daniel says I went I was sick for
certain days but and I was astonished at
the vision but no one understood it
right
Peter says the prophets who prophesied
didn't fully now that's that's kind of
another point that we're going to get on
to later but we're here so I wanted you
to see it
he says in verse 10 this of this prophet
of this salvation the prophets have
inquired and searched verse 11 focus on
verse 11 here with me searching what or
what manner of time the spirit of who
Christ who was where
in them who's them
the prophets
searching what or what manner of time
the spirit of Christ who was in the
prophets was indicating when he the
spirit of Christ did what
testified when a person testifies what
did what would you say they're giving
their testimony who was the one in the
prophet giving his testimony
Jesus so would it be then fair to say
that the testimony of the prophets was
really the testimony of Jesus
so it would be fair to say that the
spirit of Prophecy is the testimony of
Jesus and vice versa absolutely it would
so that's just one more text that we can
look at revelation we can say hey we're
on the right track here
the spirit of Prophecy is the testimony
of Jesus the prophet is a spokesperson
especially according to the scriptures
for whom
for Jesus Christ so you profess to be a
follower of Jesus I'm a gospel-centered
New Testament Jesus believe in Christian
you better believe in the spirit of
Prophecy amen